OK, up.
Dr. Anthony Foushee and other health officials
testified yesterday before the Senate.
There were a bunch of hijinx, including Senator
Rand Paul getting into an argument with Dr.
Foushee, Texas so disliked, Dr. Fouche, his
testimony that last night Lieutenant Governor
in Texas, Dan Patrick, went on Fox News and
said, we're not going to listen to Dr. Foushee
anymore.
But if you ask me, I'm listening to Foushee
before I'm listening to Dan Patrick from Texas
any day.
So what did Dr. Foushee tell us?
Some of the things he said were obvious.
Number one, Dr. Foushee said we are not really
doing that well.
We are clearly not in control of the virus.
And we could have 100000 cases a day in the
United States if things don't turn around.
Here he is saying it is going to be very disturbing.
I will guarantee you that, because when you
have an outbreak in one part of the country,
even though in other parts of the country,
they're doing well, they are vulnerable.
I made that point very clearly last week at
a press conference.
We can't just focus on those areas that are
having the surge.
It puts the entire country at risk.
We are now having 40 plus thousand new cases
a day.
I would not be surprised if we go up to 100000
a day if this does not turn around.
And so I am very concerned.
So this has already gotten so bad in at least
16 states that they've paused or reversed
some aspects of the reopening plans.
The hardest for the four hardest hit states
recently in terms of cases are Florida, Arizona,
Texas and California.
Now, if you look at growth rate of cases rather
than absolute numbers, you actually see some
other states that are not getting a lot of
attention in terms of percentage growth.
Each day they are climbing.
And if the trend doesn't reverse in 15 or
so days, you would have a very different set
of states.
That is the worst in the country in terms
of new cases.
And again, the message is we could just be
at the beginning here.
If you look at the total numbers, we cumulatively
have seen two point seven million coronavirus
cases in the United States.
If the 16 states that are problematic keep
increasing their rate of new cases, just even
10 percent a week, which is we've seen much
faster increases than that.
That two point seven million number in terms
of cumulative cases is going to go up dramatically
and very, very quickly.
You can run the numbers yourself.
If you look at fifteen, if you if we get to
15000 cases a day in Florida, 10000 a day
in Texas and California, you start seeing
that these numbers are going to add up insanely
quickly.
But the administration has moved on.
I mean, they're the Trump administration is
just done.
They are talking about reopening.
They're talking about return to greatness.
They're talking about jobs and stocks and
all of this other stuff.
We are having the work the of the four worst
the four worst days that we've had since the
beginning in terms of new cases happened in
the last five days.
Understand that.
And hilariously or tragically or I don't even
know what to call it at this point.
One of Trump's own hotels failed a Corona
virus hygiene audit.
There's these rules in terms of hotels of
how they're supposed to be cleaning surfaces
or supposed to be wiped down all of these
different rules.
Trump International in Manhattan was one of
the hotels that Inside Edition audited.
Now, you know, Inside Edition, it's sort of
like pseudo news.
But to the extent that they're telling the
truth about this, they had a correspondent
check into rooms, including at Trump's hotel
print, the program's logo, the Inside Edition
logo on the bed sheets and pillowcases and
towels using a washable spray.
And you can only see that the spray under
ultraviolet light.
But if the product is washed or wiped down,
then it goes away.
And then the Inside Edition correspondent
would make it look like someone slept in the
room.
They would leave.
Check out.
Check back in and go back to the same room
the following night.
So new as far as the hotel.
Knows this is a new customer.
A new guest, there should have been a full
cleaning done.
Trump International reportedly changed the
bed sheets, did not change the pillowcase
at all, did not wipe down the desk and other
surfaces.
So clearly, the Trump hotels are not the only
ones that are failing to meet the hygiene
requirements.
And things are looking very, very ugly in
a lot of these industries.
But many states are just full steam ahead.
So at this point, if we ask ourselves, like,
where is the ray of hope?
Where where is the possibility?
It's really in the medical field.
And governors, we have to hope that governors
will show leadership, although many of them
are not.
We have to hope that people will take this
more seriously than they've been.
I mean, it's been months, but still a lot
of people aren't taking this seriously.
And we are putting a lot of emphasis on the
medical science community that they will develop
an effective treatment, something that's better
than just, you know, 15 percent improvement
for only the sickest patients and a vaccine.
And we're really waiting on that at this point
because our country has failed.
Now, I want to remind you next, I'm going
to talk about parts of the U.S. that are doing
well, but there are countries that have dominated
this.
I spoke to a friend who lives in Belgium and
is currently in France on a vacation with
her boyfriend.
Things are great there.
I mean, on public transit, everybody's wearing
masks.
Restaurants are open with fewer tables indoors,
even outdoors.
Life has resumed very few cases now.
They are doing it.
And I'm I'm envious of that.
I admit it.
Fortunately, here in Massachusetts, things
are going well, but we are judged by the worst
of our country.
We are not allowed to travel to many parts
of the world because as a country, we are
failing.
And particularly with people able to come
in and out of states because that's the Constitution.
I'm not denying that.
We have to talk next about the states that
are doing well.
How long can they actually hold on?
Because the worse things get in some parts
of the country, eventually it's going to bleed
into the states that are taking this very
seriously.
So that let's discuss that next.